so what's the answer to the censorship
you know the Democrats censor actual
relevant political reporting by
conservatives and for 20 years or so the
the conservative response has been
censorship is bad I support Free Speech
free either you support support all all
speech or no speech oh yeah obscene
pornography totally that's a free speech
issue you have a right to it calls to
Arms to destroy the American system of
government and traditional way of life
absolutely that's protected of course
none of that is protected in the
American tradition none of that is
protected by law no the correct answer
to the to the Democrat standards and
norms and taboos that result in
censorship
is conservative censorship I know I know
it's an unpopular opinion I know that
people don't want to admit that but all
regimes all societies have some kind of
censorship
because all of them have standards and
taboos so the answer if conservatives
want to stop being such losers is we
need to engage in it ourselves not in
capricious arbitrary unjust immoral kind
of censorship but in just prudent
censorship
instead of today what we've got is they
they censor the truth they censor
goodness they censor Beauty and they
promote
lies and evil and ugliness we should we
should do the opposite okay we should
Place far more restrictions around most
notably obscene material material that
is really really wicked and hideous and
that that is what's happening we did
just score a win thanks to Instagram
Instagram just censored a post that was
aimed at teaching kids about sexual
pleasure
and I don't know maybe some of the Free
Speech absolutists are going to say no
by golly the reason we fought a
revolution in this country was to defend
social media posts teaching little
children about sexual pleasure but
that's not my point of view I think yep
that's good censor them censor them no
free speech for them
so this is the post
this is a post on on Instagram
normalizing and destigmatizing the
pursuit of pleasure sexual and otherwise
can send a strong message to children
send a strong message to children we
need to normalize it we need pleasure
censored education contrary to what some
folks assume teaching youth that sex
feels good does not cause more young
people to have sex I'm going to pause it
right there of course it does what are
you talking about
young people this would be true for
anybody for all people of all ages but
especially for young people who don't
have control over their appetites and
their actions in many cases
telling them that something feels good
telling them that this chocolate bar
over here tastes good is going to
encourage them to try it out
okay because they are repetitive
creatures that just want to pursue their
their bassist Passions
that's what it is that's why you have
education to try to Tamp that down uh
this Instagram account that posted it is
called the queer Sex Therapy Instagram
account I'm shocked totally surprised by
that and this is managed by the
expansive group
describes himself as a team of queer
therapists coaches mentors and sex
Educators that broaden Insight around
gender sexuality and relationships the
author of this post is Leia Goodman I
don't know if it's a man or a woman or
if Leia's her or his real name I don't
know anymore because these people are so
deeply confused but this individual
describes him or herself as a queer
educator and uses she slash they
pronouns so this is obviously grooming
this is obviously obscene this should be
ostracized censored and these people
should probably be imprisoned
the question though that a lot of people
keep asking when they're trying to come
to a nice nice conservative conciliatory
Middle Ground here well we don't want to
censor anybody we don't want to cast any
aspersions anybody but they'll say but
but why do kids
need to see this kind of material
from the adults
from the queer Therapy Group why why do
the kids need to see this that's not the
right question
obviously the kids don't need to see
this the question to be asking is
why do the queer Sex Therapy people
feel the need to show this to children
the question is now why do kids need to
see drag queen Story Hour at the public
library
they don't of course
the question is why do the drag queen
Story Hour people feel this deep need
to dance around in sexually provocative
clothing for little children
because they are perverts and sexual
deviants and at the ideological level
they want to pervert the whole culture
and it's much easier to do that when you
focus on kids because kids brains are
very malleable so if you get them young
and give them a vision of the world it's
more likely to stick in the long term
and then at the physical level
they probably have weird sexual
appetites for kids right right I I go
back to this great tweet that has gone
viral from Oren McIntyre which says it's
not that complicated guys the these
people are evil and they just want to
diddle kids
and I think there's some truth to that I
think there's a broader ideological
aspect to it
that and the left is written about this
for well over a hundred years
because sex is so important to people
because it's so it's Central to human
nature if you can
twist the way that people think about
sex you can transform the whole culture
and the way to really twist that is to
get to people at a young age I think I
think that exists I don't think that
just derives from you know some disorder
and sexual desire but then I think also
a number of people who have performed a
drag queen Story Hour are child
molesters that's not it that's not a
coincidence okay that's not just a
random accident
yeah it's the people who are really
obsessed with talking to little kids
about sex probably have weird sexual
Hang-Ups when it comes to kids so the
answer to that is censor it pass laws
against it put these people in prison
okay I think that's actually a pretty
moderate solution the Democrats are
talking about shooting all of us if we
dare suggest that maybe we should kill
fewer babies a year the Democrats are
talking about shooting all of us if we
if we say that maybe we shouldn't
castrate eight-year-olds the Democrats
are talking about shooting us killing us
killing Mega voters calling us Nazis
saying we need to be treated like Osama
Bin Laden if we consider voting for
Donald Trump if we consider voting for
one of the two parties in our alleged
two-party system
you're talking about killing us
okay I think at the very least we can
put child molesters in prison and and
pass laws against the grooming and the
bizarre cultural transformation that
these people are are leading right now
you got to go to established titles.com
Knowles because I tell you there was a
period when I felt like I wasn't getting
no respect no respect I tell you and
then that all changed thanks to
established titles now
I Am Lord Michael Knowles and you can be
a lord or a lady as well you can get the
respect that you deserve all you need is
a one square foot plot of land in
Scotland established titles is a Project
based on an historic Scottish custom
where landowners are referred to as
Lance or Lords and Ladies in English in
your title pack you will be bestowed
with at least one square foot of
dedicated land on a private estate in
edelston Scotland plus an official
certificate with a Crest your
certificate features a unique plot
Number with which you can see the exact
location of your land title packs from
established titles are a fun and unique
gift for any occasion there are even
couple packs because you don't want to
be a Lord and then your poor wife
doesn't get to be a lady with your
certificate you could officially add the
prefix Lord or lady to your credit cards
plane tickets even your dating profiles
a plus established titles commits to
preserving The Woodlands not only in
Scotland but around the planet
they've got Partnerships with global
Charities like one tree planted and
trees for the future to help with our
afforestation efforts and for every
order they receive a tree is planted
established titles told me get this
the first 200 people purchasing a title
pack using my exclusive link will
receive a plot within a few walking
minutes of mine that's right so
depending on how many of you want to
become a lord or a lady we can build our
own kingdom and that will be a wonderful
and it will be run with an iron fist
established titles is actually running a
massive sale right now if you use code
Knolls you'll get on top of that an
additional 10 off go to
establishtitles.com get your gifts right
now and help support the channel
I'm so glad you like that clip now
all right you got to ring that Bell
subscribe get the notifications we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]